la fiscal general de ucrania recibe a
los investigadores forenses de la
policía armada de francia los 16
especialistas ayudarán a las autoridades
ucranianas en lucha durante las próximas
dos semanas a investigar si se
cometieron crímenes contra los civiles
tenemos algunos equipos en el lugar
tenemos científicos forenses que
examinarán los cuerpos para determinar
la causa de la muerte y también tenemos
un laboratorio móvil para que los
científicos averigüen su identidad a
través de su adn
rusia se retiró del suburbio de kiev a
finales de marzo pocos días después las
autoridades ucranianas descubrieron unos
250 cadáveres en una fosa común lo que
provocó un clamor mundial los
investigadores tratarán de establecer
quiénes son las víctimas y cómo murieron
como lo que ocurrió con estos son chivos
residentes extraer impotente gente sirio
cns es muy importante contar con las
decisiones de la corte penal
internacional o de otros tribunales
internacionales por eso es muy relevante
que los investigadores y expertos de
otras jurisdicciones tenga la
posibilidad de venir a ucrania no somos
un país cerrado la recopilación de
pruebas es la especialidad de estos
policías franceses
estamos examinando todo lo que se puede
encontrar armas heridas etcétera hemos
enviado cirujanos plásticos y
especialistas en explosivos para
determinar qué causó la serie desde las
víctimas víctima las pruebas que las
autoridades francesas y ucranianas
cotejen serán entregadas a la corte
penal internacional para determinar si
rusia cometió crímenes de guerra en
ucrania